So our app isn't the most exciting or
interactive website
that's ever been created.
Let's spruce it up a bit by adding
an order manager to it that
will track what we're eating each day.
We'll build up this order manager with
templates, controllers and a service.
We'll need to create the service
that will be responsible for
managing the orders.
This service will need to keep track
of what has been ordered for each day.
To do that we can create a simple object
to keep track of each day's items.
We also need to keep track of
the currently selected day, so
the user will know which day
they're ordering a menu item for.
For this service to be useful,
it needs to manage this data.
Consumers of this service should be
able to get the current list of orders.
They should also be able to get and
set the active day.
And last they should be able to
choose an item for a meal and
then remove an item from a meal.
The order manager is now capable of
tracking anything the user wants to
eat for any meal.
Let's create a template and
control it to let the user keep
track of their menu items.
We need a template that
will display our orders and
a controller that will set the initial
state for the template's expressions.
Now let's add that template to the page.
To get the data to our template we need
to inject the order manager service
into the controller.
Remember we do that by passing
an array of items to inject and
then the controller function
as the last item in the array.
Now we can set the list property of
the controller to the orders returned by
the order manager.
The controller is all set, so
we can now start modifying the template.
We want to show the orders for
each meal and
we want to repeat this list for
every day.
That means we need
the ng-repeat directive.
The first time through
day will be Monday and
menu category will be this object.
So now let's add the data
to our template.
So we can now track orders but
the user doesn't have any
way to pick a menu item.
In the menu template we'll add this
section where the user can pick when
they want to eat this menu item.
And we'll need a button to let
them actually pick the meal.
When the user clicks on this button
we'll send along the item's name and
when they want to eat it.
We'll need to create this
choose item function.
So in menu.js we'll create it.
Order information is managed by
the order manager service, so we need to
inject it into this controller so
we can pass along the data.
Order manager already has
a method to let us add an item so
we'll just pass the data to it.
Now we can select an item and
choose when to eat it and
add it to the order manager.
How cool is that?
Except we can only pick items for
Monday.
Let's fix that.
In the order template we need to make it
so that when we click on a specific day,
we'll update the order manager's
active day to that one.
So if Tuesday's clicked,
we'll pass that along and
tell order manager to update
its active day to Tuesday.
We just made a bunch of
modifications to our app and
it's really starting to come together.
If you got lost along the way,
just step back and
remember what we're trying to do.
Services maintain our data.
We inject services into controllers, so
that controllers have
access to that data.
And then we display
that data in templates.
And again, services aren't tied to
specific views or controllers as we saw
with the order manager service that we
injected into two separate controllers.